wir müssen hier über immer mehr
todesopfer auf auch berichten auch zwei
junge ukrainische fußballer das gab
jetzt die weltweite spielervereinigung
fifpro am dienstag bekannt nachwuchs
torwart vitali safilo und karipidis von
der dritten liga beide erst mitte
zwanzig der haben zuletzt für den fc
host to mail gespielt sind wir sehen
hier die familie von vitali in kiew
gestorben und hier sehen sie unseren
reporter philipp potthoff er hat mit der
familie von vitali gesprochen die jetzt
dieses schweres schicksal zu verkraften
haben und es uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet
findet erzählt uns einmal wie musste die
familie von vitali von seinem tragischen
tod erfahren
er ist einer von vielen soldaten diese
tapfer gekämpft haben und dann bei der
verteidigung der hauptstadt hier
gefallen sind ich war gestern mit meinem
kollegen til biermann bei der familie in
einem kleinen dorf in der nähe von
lemberg und konnte mit dem vater noch
mit dem großvater von vitali sprechen
und der vater da wo man hat mir erzählt
dass sein sohn vitaly der ein junger
panzerkommandant war 21 jahre alt
unbedingt kämpfen wollte unbedingt sein
land verteidigen wollte zuerst ist ein
erster panzer kaputt gegangen er ist
dann sofort zum zweiten hat sich den
genommen und als auch der dann im
gefecht kaputt ging hat er gesagt gebt
mir im dritten panzer ich will auf
keinen fall weg von der front und dann
hat er diesen dritten panzer bekommen
und wie sein vater gesagt hat dieser
panzer hat ihn in den ewigen schlaf
gebracht die familie ist natürlich
wahnsinnig traurig schockiert können
dass alle noch kaum glauben dass ihr
sohn enkel ihr bruder gestorben ist der
großvater hat fast die ganze zeit
geweint und hat gesagt wer wird sich
denn jetzt fragen opa kann ich noch
einen 20er von dir haben so hat er ihn
immer genannt mein kleiner zwanziger
das ganze dorf ist schockiert
einwohner kommen natürlich zu der
familie und versuchen zu helfen und zu
trösten auf haben unsere unterstützung
angeboten
ich habe auch den vater gefragt ob es
jetzt dann vielleicht die ukraine zu
verlassen aber für sie ist ganz klar sie
bleiben der vater hat gesagt mein kind
liegt hier begraben
und hier bleibe ich
philipp die worte die auch du jetzt
benutzt das gefallene soldaten im
gefecht dort in der hauptstadt in kiew
das geht uns jetzt allen schon so über
die lippen das ist eine woche krieg
jetzt aber auch diese begriffe sind
jetzt mittlerweile in der ukraine
offenbar allgegenwärtig
absolut das land ist ist im krieg die
menschen haben das hier wirklich
verinnerlicht und man muss dazu
natürlich sagen das land ist eigentlich
seit acht jahren in einem in einer art
krieg putin ist ja seit 2014 mit seinen
truppen in der ukraine hat dort
pro-russische separatisten finanziert
und ausgestattet und hochgerüstet aber
dass dieser krieg jetzt so groß wird und
das ganze langsam fast was so russland
wirklich hier einmarschiert das hat hier
niemand gedacht aber die leute haben
sofort umgeschaltet
und dinge wie die luftschutzkeller wie
gefallene soldaten männer die sich an
die front melden das ist hier alltag ich
stehe hier auch an einem eingang zum
luftschutzkeller des hotels weil bei uns
gerade luftalarm ist er in lemberg man
muss dazu sagen in lemberg ist bis